[Music]
as I learned from growing up you don't
mess with your grandmother and what she
says goes all hail the Queen we're
taking a look at all the ways she is a
total boss
mommy for starters the queen is funny
great pleasure that I welcome you all
here this evening Thank You mr. Prime
Minister of Canada for making me feel so
old
really and she seems to be game for
pretty much anything including starring
alongside James Bond himself Daniel
Craig to open the 2012 London Olympic
Games and we know she loves to play the
ponies
Queen Elizabeth the second is the
longest reigning monarch in British
history and I've seen one one coronation
and being the recipient in the other P
pretty remarkable and she's one tough
lady just asked the crown actress Claire
Foy so you've met her briefly well of
course it's brie if it's not like you're
hanging out with her it's very brief at
brief and so she gives you a hand back
she invented the Shelf back she said she
really cos you were having back after
you've met her boy has learned
everything there is to know about the
Queen in order to make her portrayal as
accurate as possible
she's an outdoorsy person and I'm not
not outdoorsy but she just you know
outdoors people just are more like look
just get on with things a bit more she
is one tough broad she really is a tough
broad that's a really good way to
describe her as a broad she really has a
broad
now we can't talk about the Queen
without talking about her fashion
mothers and members of the House of
Commons she the woman who wears many
hats both literally and figuratively
it gives me particular pleasure but this
visit comes so soon after a vivid and
effective demonstration of the
long-standing alliance between our two
countries it said the queen is sported
an estimated 5000 hats in the past 50
years when it comes to birthdays the
Queen's is one of a kind she actually
has to her real birthday on April 21st
and the public celebration trooping the
colors that takes place on the second
Saturday of June and basically shuts
down London
[Music]
over 1,400 soldiers 200 horses and 400
musicians take part in the event so it's
quite the spectacle
despite her regal title and status Queen
Elizabeth is one supportive granny the
more grandmother bits the more I can get
advice and and suck all that information
I'm a father
and the whole experience that she's had
for so long things were rapidly building
out steam towards the wedding and I was
given a list in the first meeting of 777
names and not one of them on there I
knew and I wasn't happy about it so I
rang her for a bit of a sort of moral
support of a bit of backup and she said
there is the ridiculous and get rid of
the list and start from your friends
she's been very generous and not sort of
being forceful at all and any of her
views but she's just I feel she's been
there sort of a gentle guidance ready
for me she has that amazing ability to
to make anyone relax on that that's a
skill in itself and she's she's very
good at it but we want to know what's
your favorite thing about Queen
Elizabeth and the royal family
[Music]